so in this video I'm going to be sharing
17 of the biggest YouTube mistakes I've
made over the past 17 years that could
be costing you views subscribers and
respect I learned that nobody cared
never upload a video your subscribers
didn't subscribe for I was allowing
perfectionism to hold me back the better
your systems the better the results
you're going to get on YouTube this one
is probably the biggest mistake I've
made consistently and it's this
so in this video I'm going to be sharing
17 of the biggest YouTube mistakes I've
made over the past 17 years that could
be costing you views subscribers and
respect so stay tuned to see which ones
you're guilty of and you won't believe
number 11 number one not making eye
contact with the lens one of the most
common mistakes especially for new
creators is looking at the selfie screen
instead of the lens the problem is if
you're not making eye contact with the
lens this creates a disconnect between
you and the viewer and can hurt audience
retention mistake number two not
starting when I first started YouTube I
was uploading videos for my church but I
had the desire to start a Channel of my
own however I hesitated for 3 years I
was waiting until I felt ready waiting
for the perfect camera I was allowing
perfectionism to hold me back but the
truth is you got to start before you're
ready you got to start poop your pants
scared you got to just punch fear in the
face punch perfectionism in the face and
press record which brings us to mistake
number three and that is focusing on
gear instead of the content so there's
actually a technical term called gas
that stands for gear acquisition
syndrome this refers to the dopamine
rush you get from buying new gears or
accessories that you don't actually need
this actually appeared in Guitar Player
magazine back in 1996 as guitar
acquisition syndrome but it can apply to
anything equipment that you buy but
don't use books you buy but don't read
software that you buy but you never
Master it the key point here is that to
succeed on YouTube you actually have to
upload videos on YouTube and it's not
the camera that's going to make the
difference it's the content that's going
to make the difference so start with
whatever camera that you already have
and level up as you go mistake number
four is a lack of planning when I first
got started with video on YouTube I made
the mistake of winging it instead of
planning ahead a lot of times this would
look like just having a vague idea or no
idea for the video at all just turning
the camera on starting to capture
footage ending up with tons of extra
footage not knowing how to sort through
it and how to really edit a final
product because I didn't plan ahead what
I learned was that the cure to this was
starting with the end in mind and then
reverse engineering backwards what's
this video about what's the title what's
the thumbnail what footage do I need
what kind of story do I want to tell
what's the messaging here and I found
that a few minutes of planning led to an
exponential return on not just my energy
but on the views and subscribers and
impact that the final video had which
brings us to to mistake number five and
that is comparing yourself and trying to
be somebody else I found that sometimes
watching others can make me inspired and
at other times it actually can make me
insecure I learned that comparison is a
killer of creativity and it's a thief of
Joy because when I look at somebody
else's gifts talents and abilities that
I don't have that usually doesn't lead
me to a place of feeling encouraged and
inspired to create my own content
however by identifying your own
strengths what makes you uniquely you
and tap into your own authenticity
whether that's your quirks your humor
your stoic personality your bubbly
personality a huge key to your success
on YouTube is being you times two and
not trying to be somebody else now smash
the like button if you've been getting
value so far and let's hit number six
which is making selfish content the
co-author of our book YouTube Secrets
Benji Travis sat down with Gary
vaynerchuk in his office a while back
and here's what he said are you putting
out entertainment are you putting out
education because 90% of people are
putting out selfish content the truth is
YouTube is your tube you can make
whatever videos you want but that
doesn't mean anybody's going to watch
them or that anybody is going to give
you views and subscribers and attention
if you want your videos to perform
better ask this question what value does
this video add to the viewer what topics
are people actually searching for what
topics are people people actually
interested in mistake number seven weak
titles no joke I actually posted
hundreds of videos before learning how
important titles were mistakes I made it
included doing an interview with
somebody and just putting their first
and last name in the word interview with
no detail about what the viewer would
learn in the video really early on I'm
guilty of making videos titled promo
video. mpp4 I mean I've made some big
mistakes in my career and the cool thing
is with tools like chat GPT and vid iq's
AI coach you can easily power up your
titles without being a genius at writing
them and the cool thing is with tools
like chat GPT and vid iq's AI coach you
can start writing great titles even if
you're an absolute beginner now you
might have saw this one coming but M
snake number eight is weak thumbnails
believe it or not when I started YouTube
you couldn't even upload custom
thumbnails but now not only do we have
opportunity very soon everyone's going
to have the ability to split test three
different thumbnails some of the
mistakes I see people make with
thumbnails includes too much clutter
there's too many words there's too many
images there's an overall lack of
clarity don't forget a lot of people are
consuming YouTube on their smartphone so
another mistake is having your images or
your text be too small and unreadable
the cool thing is there's a lot of
innovation happening with AI That's
making graphic design even easier and
tools like canva make it easy to create
great thumbnails even if you're just
starting out number nine is wasting time
during the start of your video ever
since I started creating videos and
editing I've been using Adobe Premiere
and I remember eventually I discovered a
program called After Effects this
allowed me to make a really cool intro
with music and a logo and sound effects
but here's the problem I learned that
nobody cared if you're starting your
video with a 10c 20 second swooping logo
that's got some electricity and a cool
sound effect you are wasting the viewers
time and hurting your videos performance
unless you have a faceless Channel when
the video starts you want to cut right
to the chase with you on camera with a
powerful question a powerful opening and
a powerful hook seriously just fixing
that mistake will radically improve the
performance of your YouTube channel now
not a lot of people talk about mistake
number 10 but here's what it is not
creating systems the Landmark book
Atomic habits revealed a powerful truth
and it's this we don't rise to the level
of our goals we fall to the level of our
systems if you think about it when it
comes to YouTube everybody has the same
goals I want to get a th000 subscribers
I want to get a silver play button I
want to go full-time I want my business
to grow from the views and awareness
that my channel generates but of course
a lot of people struggle to reach their
goals and one of the reasons that
happens is because of a lack of systems
and so what are system well they are the
habits and the patterns and the routines
and the checklists that you install into
your life so that you can produce
consistent results on YouTube this is
one of the reasons why I created the V
system that is a process that I've used
and now tens of thousands of people in
our community have used to create
consistent results on YouTube this
process of reverse engineering and then
researching and then recording and then
releasing the video the right way and
then UL timately reviewing the results
and repeating the process and one of the
reasons to subscribe to this video
podcast is because we are obsessed with
systems a system for your shoot day a
system for when you're creating videos
when you're releasing videos and the
better your systems the better the
results you're going to get on YouTube
now in just a second we're going to hit
mistake number 11 but if you like this
video and you're interested in learning
more about my YouTube growth system that
I teach in my program video ranking
Academy you can just go to VAP
podcast.com or click the link in the
description because for a limited time
we have special pricing and bonuses but
that's ending soon so check out the link
and let's keep the video moving we got
to hit mistake number 11 and here's what
it is sacrificing your long-term brand
for shortterm money this includes
pushing products you don't actually
believe in or jumping on trends that
don't actually align with your channel
topic this is a huge Temptation that new
creator ERS fall into because you're so
hungry to grow the channel to do this
full-time you're so flattered perhaps by
getting an invitation to your first
brand deal or sponsorship and all of
those things are good making money
getting views building your personal
brand but if you're compromising what
you actually believe about a product or
you're chasing views and vanity
metrics disconnected from the core
purpose of your channel then ultimately
you're going to be sacrificing your
long-term brand just for shortterm views
and money and let me just encourage you
that after 17 years on YouTube sitting
here now I look back and I regret any
time that I've made shortsighted
decisions instead of decisions based on
Legacy impact and the ultimate brand
that I want to build mistake number 12
unrealistic expectations the reality is
there are true stories of people who've
experienced YouTube success in a matter
of day days and weeks but the odds of
that happening is like one in a million
it's like winning the lottery yes
Goldman Sachs research revealed that the
crater economy is going to double in
value over the next few years yes
there's 2.7 billion monthly active users
on YouTube right now yes over 200
million people have earned money from
content creation that's old stats
revealed by tube filter the opportunity
is real the chance for growth is real
but YouTube is a marathon and not a
Sprint it is a mistake to underestimate
the amount of work and grit and patience
and time and learning and skill building
that it takes to succeed on YouTube but
the good news is if you go into this
with the right mentality realizing that
Rome wasn't built in a day it was built
Brick by Brick your YouTube channel
won't be built in a day it'll be built
one video at a time over time so just
get started and have realistic
expectations mistake number 13 is
covering too many topics on one channel
one of my favorite things to do is look
back at my Sean canel YouTube channel
and reflect on the different topics I
covered in the span of like 20 videos
one week I posted a video with camera
tips and Equipment tips which is a great
topic but then I posted a video
reviewing a bark box subscription with
toys and treats for our two Chihuahua
then I posted a video with my green
beans recipe and man that thing got over
like 60,000 views so I thought I'm
Martha Stewart I'm Anthony Bourdain but
then I abandoned that dream and I did my
review of The Amazing Spider-Man like
what happened is my channel a movie
review Channel now like where am I going
with this then I posted a vlog with my
wife Sonia doing Las Vegas horseback
riding and then I topped it all off with
my extra special Shin Ramen recipe I was
all over the place I was covering too
many topics on one channel and my growth
was suffering as a result so here's a
phrase worth remembering or writing down
never upload a video your subscribers
didn't subscribe for answering that
question will force you to Define who is
your channel for and what value does
your channel provide for the viewer it's
also worth considering that if you've
already been posting videos and getting
subscribers why are they clicking
subscribe what topics are they clicking
subscribe for and if you Veer away from
those topics then don't be surprised
when your use suffer mistake 14 trying
to figure things out on your own listen
I've got the utmost respect for hard
work grit putting in the time just
putting your head down and grinding
that's cool but did you know that
there's a better way like rather than
trying to figure out everything out on
your own you could ask the question who
knows how to do this that I could learn
from and I understand I'm preaching to
the choir because you're literally
watching a video about YouTube strategy
but I want to encourage you don't try to
Pioneer your own path when someone else
has already blazed away educational
YouTube videos from trusted sources
that's a shortcut books and audio books
on topics like marketing online business
communication strategy that's a shortcut
developing relationships online and
offline through events through groups of
other people that can help you up your
YouTube game that's a shortcut online
courses and education programs that
teach you specific skills and help you
go faster that's a shortcut of course
there is no substitute for you putting
in the practice and putting in the work
but trying to figure everything out on
your own is the slowest Road and so go
faster by getting help now mistake
number 15 is inconsistency now you may
be thinking Sean I've heard that before
but here's the thing most people really
talk about being consistent in one
dimension and I have at least five
Dimensions to share with you now of
course the First Dimension is uploads
like you actually have to upload videos
on YouTube to be successful on YouTube
and the more consistent your uploads
over time the better your results but
that's really just one dimension the
second is consistent energy and what I
mean is a consistent tone a consistent
feel to your videos it's almost like
saying a consistent quality but another
dimension would be a consistent energy
like are you showing up with the same
level of energy and the same level of
quality in your videos now another
dimension of consistency be your message
are you staying on brand on message are
you covering so many topics kind of like
we covered in the last point or do you
have a consistent theme un through line
through all of your content and think
about how that one relates to building
your brand I mean are you saying what
people want to hear or are you saying
what you actually believe we've all seen
politicians who say one thing to a
particular crowd and then they change
their message for another crowd that
hurts hurts their credibility and even
another dimension could be a consistent
brand do your videos does your content
have a consistent look does it have a
consistent feel is there a cohesive
brand or does it just feel all over the
place random no theme no through line
all of these things make up consistency
and the more consistent you are with
your content on YouTube the more
momentum that you'll build over time now
when I think about my 17 years on
YouTube and I think about mistake 16
this one is probably the biggest mistake
I've made consistently and it's this
trying to do too many things at once a
lot of times people will come to me and
say okay I get it I shouldn't have too
many topics on one channel so instead
I'm going to start like two or three
channels to divide up my content big
mistake you see if you try and Chase
three rabbits you'll end up catching
none of them and I'm massively guilty of
this cuz I think it was 2014 or 2015
when I realized I was operating four or
five channels I had the think
International channel the think media
channel my Clear Vision media channel my
Sean canel Channel and the video
influencers channel stupid if there's
one Banner lesson I've learned in my
career it's that you need to focus and
focus stands for follow one course until
successful if you're multi-passionate
and you want to do multiple YouTube
channels I want to challenge you what is
the strongest one which one are you most
passionate about most efficient at and
also has the best opportunity of
producing an income and money because
fast forward to today and I do run
multiple channels but I've also built a
team that supports me this might be the
biggest mistake that creators and
entrepreneurs and the ambitious make
overall too many social media platforms
too many projects too many YouTube
channels too many ideas not enough
execution on one thing so make a plan
work the plan kill distractions and
protect your focus which brings us to
mistake number 17 which is giving up too
soon but here's the thing if you're
feeling frustrated or discouraged with
your growth on YouTube I don't blame you
in fact I made an entire video about
this point and you can click or tap the
screen to watch that video or check it
out in the show notes I break down some
science-backed principles for staying
motivated on YouTube and crashing
through quitting points so I look
forward to seeing you in that episode